p
les freins à l'arrivée des véhicules
autonomes sont légaux et aussi
réglementaire ce que le gouvernement
canadien veut maintenant réglé avec les
provinces
mills il ya aussi les problèmes d'ordre
technique entre le conducteur et la
nouvelle technologie
comment garder la vigilance du
conducteur réveillée lorsqu'il pourrait
aussi très facilement sans dormir ou
consulté son téléphone intelligent on
sait comment ça se passe aujourd'hui
dans un laboratoire de transports canada
à ottawa on mène actuellement des tests
dans un simulateur de conduite pour
évaluer le temps de réaction d'un
conducteur quand il est distrait durant
la conduite d'un véhicule partiellement
autonome il doit pouvoir intervenir dans
un délai de deux secondes au delà de ça
il y un risque de collision on ne veut
pas le bombarder d'alert de sons et de
signaux lumineux sans qu'il sache trop
quoi faire
il faut le guider vers la bonne réaction
avancer une voiture sur le marché
imaginez que la voiture roule sans
problème pendant des kilomètres qu'elle
rencontre une situation plus difficile
et disent ok je lâche le volant prend le
relais
ce n'est pas une situation dans laquelle
on veut placer le conducteur la
distraction ici n'a rien à voir avec un
coup d'oeil qu'on pourrait jeter un
écran ou un appareil dans l'auto pendant
une seconde ou deux on parle plutôt
d'une distraction de 30 secondes ou de
plusieurs minutes
le conducteur a très peu conscience de
ce qui se passe sur la route et tout
d'un coup on lui demande du côté de
l'ordinateur de reprendre le contrôle
absolu
sauf que rapporte un décès car même au
mois de mai dernier en floride
il ya une voiture d'un homme qui était
en conduite semi autonome qui a frappé
un semi remorque malheureusement il ya
eu un décès est-ce que c'est venu
freiner le développement si je pensais
que oui moi j'ai été très touché par
cette histoire l'homme a un homme de 40
ans joshua brown qui était vraiment pro
conduite autonome c'était vraiment un
homme qui militait pour la chose est
encore aujourd'hui sur son you tube on
voit beaucoup de vidéos où il déclarait
la conduite autonome a sauvé la vie at
elle été l'événement
moi je parle quand il est décédé bon il
ya toutes sortes d'explications il ya
une enquête en cours on ne saura plus
tard quand il est décédé je me suis dit
tout les autorités à travers le monde
vont reculer sur la cause autonome et ça
a été tout à fait le contraire au canada
63% des citoyens affirmé dans un récent
sondage ils n'oseraient pas être
passager d'une voiture qui se conduit
seul
on dit souvent que la technologie domine
le monde alors c'est plutôt l'inversé
qui est en train de se passer avec les
voitures autonomes et beaucoup d'autres
nouvelles technologies c'est à dire que
c'est c'est beaucoup plus la société qui
est en train de dicter aux concepteurs
comment on aimerait on souhaiterait
utiliser la technologie michel lejeune
et coordinateur des cours de sociologie
de la technologie à l'institut
polytechnique de montréal alors il ya un
débat actuellement dans la société
à ce niveau là pour faire une histoire
courte
lorsqu'on parle de nouvelles
technologies dans les sociétés on passe
à travers trois étapes une première
étape de conception et la deuxième étape
c'est l'étape de diffusion où on
implante on la teste on la vend et il ya
une troisième une dernière étape qui
s'appelle l'appropriation sociale la
technologie c'est là que les citoyens
comme vous et moi achetant les voitures
électrique en ce moment où autonome
éventuelles ils peuvent dire non la
nouvelle technologie peut rester sur une
tablette parce que la société n'est pas
intéressée où elle est inquiète
est ce qu'on veut on peut prendre
l'exemple des états unis on veut éviter
d'avoir des règles différentes d'un pays
à l'autre
on veut uniformiser parce qu'imaginez
que aujourd'hui ce serait impensable que
je conduis mon auto et puis je passais
en ontario puis on l'a on dit ah bah non
je suis désolé la fois la d re prenait
le contrôle votre véhicule n'est pas
autorisée sur nos côtes
nicolas sony et professeur à l'école
polytechnique de montréal
effectivement les usagers vont
s'approprier la technologie mais je
pense que les technologiques ont
tellement davantage que elles sont
extrêmement attractive et ses avantages
vont être maximum uniquement que si on
n'a que des autos autonome conduite par
qui ne sont plus conduit par les humains
sur la route un reportage de radio
canada international